what are you good at  what are you what are you naturally good  at what are your strengths but  school doesn't custom tailor their  curriculum and teaching based on your  strength your personality your passion  and your interest that's the biggest  problem so that's why school is designed  to create employees it's designed to be  almost like a assembly line right it's  not designed for you to to flourish to  to exercise fully exercise your talents  or your creativity so what i suggest all  the young people when i told the the  young the young gentleman and that would  be the same advice i would give you is  this you could go to college perfectly  fine if that's what you want to do is  that's what you want to learn but  beyond that you need to develop other  skill sets and and explore other  skill sets maybe  find out what other things that you may  be good at